economía en france 24 está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buenas
noches comenzamos con un escándalo sobre
un lavado de activos multimillonario por
parte de varios bancos que estarían
implicados en esta trama santiago muy
buenas noches mire este es el resultado
de una investigación global de más de un
año por parte de unos 400 periodistas
del consorcio internacional de
periodismo de investigación pues entre
los hallazgos se encontró que varios de
los grandes bancos del mundo habrían
facilitado entre 1999 y 2017 un supuesto
lavado de alrededor de 2 billones de
dólares entre las principales fuentes
usadas está la filtración de más de 2000
informes que hablan o daban cuenta al
gobierno de eeuu de actividades
sospechosas y lo sospechoso era que los
bancos a veces no reportaban millonarias
transacciones de dudosa procedencia como
deberían haberlo hecho entre los
señalados están en salpicados de los
cinco más grandes bancos del mundo como
por ejemplo jaypee morgan
el 2 bank el standard chartered y bank
of new york mellon y pues varios de
ellos se defendieron también en cámping
station
nos estamos tomando en serio la lucha
contra el blanqueo de capitales estamos
cooperando estrechamente con las
autoridades de investigación criminal al
igual que otros bancos lo que se informa
ahora no es nuevo ni para nosotros ni
para nuestro supervisor es alex of kabah
daniela también hay expectativa en eeuu
por quién será el dueño de las
operaciones de 'tik tok' en ese país
norteamericano si el gobierno de eeuu
bendijo preliminarmente un acuerdo para
que oracle y walmart tengan
participaciones en tick tock global que
es la empresa que posiblemente nacerá
después de que entren como socios estas
dos compañías pero lo que no está claro
santiago es quién es finalmente el que
va a quedar con el control de la firma
porque todos se entregan declaraciones
contradictorias
ahora con y walmart dicen que el control
quedaría en manos de estadounidenses
pero bait de ans dice que tendrá el 80
por ciento de participación incluso
afirmó que lanzaría una oferta pública
de acciones
esto último es lo que no le gusta al
presidente don nacho si podemos salvar
el acuerdo lo salvaremos y si no podemos
no descartaremos pero ellos tienen algo
preliminar veremos que pueden hacer
tenemos que tener seguridad total eso es
lo único muy importante
seguimos en eeuu daniela la riqueza en
ese país norteamericano se recuperó en
este segundo trimestre si pues entre
abril y junio lo hizo a niveles
históricos según datos revelados hoy por
la reserva federal el patrimonio neto de
las familias subió casi un 7% hasta 119
billones de dólares cuando en el primer
trimestre había sido de un poco más de
111 billones de dólares
cuando hablamos de patrimonio neto
santiago nos referimos al valor de las
casas más lo que tengan en sus cuentas
bancarias malas acciones los bonos y
otros activos y a todo esto se le resta
la deuda hipotecaria los préstamos para
automóviles las deudas de las tarjetas
de crédito y otros préstamos otro
aspecto a destacar es que las ganancias
fluyeron hacia los
más ricos el 10% de la población de eeuu
tiene unas dos terceras partes de toda
esa riqueza de la que hablamos la
economía para dormir como debe ser
daniela hablemos ahora del gobierno de
méxico que inició la investigación a las
importaciones de acero específicamente
láminas de acero que provienen de brasil
y de rusia y que entre 2017 y 2019 al
parecer fueron objeto de prácticas
desleales que distorsionan por supuesto
el precio de este material pues así lo
denuncian algunos productores locales
que dicen que en este periodo las
importaciones de este producto crecieron
un 15 por ciento mientras que la
producción nacional de zinc disminuyó en
una cuarta parte en efecto brasil es el
país que más láminas de acero exporta a
méxico y rusia también es un importante
proveedor muy claro
daniela a continuación los indicadores
como las fal las principales bolsas en
la jornada comenzamos hoy en europa
porque hubo un desplome de gen
generalizado de más del 3 por ciento en
los principales índices bursátiles
el dax tuvo su mayor pérdida desde marzo
bolsa de madrid desde junio todo por
cuenta de la segunda ola de contagios
que ha originado nuevas restricciones y
que también originó descensos en eeuu y
en américa latina también pues el
contagio de este resultado que además se
notó e igualmente los precios del
petróleo que suele hoy cayeron más del
4% santiago
muchas gracias daniela por esta
actualización de las noticias del mundo
económico es todo por el momento aquí en
france24 siga con nosotros
[Música]